Boa noite, minhas amigas, meus amigos.
Por favor,
dê o seu boa noite também. Conforme
vocês forem entrando, me digam se estão
me ouvindo bem, se o áudio tá legal. Boa
noite, Eliseu. Boa noite, Dra. Ana
Paula, Cristina Carol, Vilma. É um
prazer tê-los aqui. Eu quero que vocês
me dê o feedback pra gente poder já
começar respondendo as perguntas, tá? Eu
vou esperar o feedback.
Boa noite também, Antônio Renato.
Estão me ouvindo bem?
Ouvindo bem. Ótimo. Então vou começar
aqui. A Vilma já confirmou.
Doutor, parabéns pelo seu trabalho.
Obrigado.
Gostaria de saber se é normal quando
tomamos muitos suplementos, temos
arrutos mais do que o normal. Sim, é bem
comum isso daí.
Quando se toma muitos suplementos,
especialmente aqueles que não têm aquela
chamada cobertura né, chamada DRCAPs,
ou mesmo quando é tomado em horários
inadequados, podem fermentar, né, no
estômago, isso causar um acúmulo de gás
e arrotos em excesso, tá? Lembrando que
vários desses suplementos que nós
tomamos também é comida das bactérias.
Além disso, tem suplementos que não tm
uma matriz digestiva apropriada, né?
Isso pode causar um problema de prejuízo
no ambiente do ácido do estômago.
Isso pode afetar a produção de ácido
clorídrico e causar uma digestão lenta
ou deficiente. Isso para alguns tipos de
suplementos ou de medicamentos.
Então, a solução prática é avaliar a
qualidade do suplemento, certificar de
que tem boas absorção, uma boa cobertura
né, pedir pra farmácia fazer DRCF,
muitas vezes ajuda.
Considerar também o suporte digestório
com uso de enzimas digestivas e o
cloridado betaína, tá? Eu vou ter que
ser bem objetivo, pessoal, porque hoje
tem bastante pergunta, tá? E
provavelmente eu não vou conseguir
responder as perguntas que estão sendo
feitas agora aí no chat.
da transmissão
sobre a suplementação de curcumina para
desempenho esportivo. Podemos tomar três
vezes ao dia junto com refeições? Sim, é
perfeitamente possível. Geralmente se
toma duas vezes ao dia, mas três vezes
não vejo problema nenhum.
Tem vários estudos aí mostrando uso de
curina a mas aí não é curcumina de alta
absorção. 2,5 g
distribuídas ao longo do dia. Então não
há nenhum problema de você tá utilizando
três vezes ao dia.
E quanto mais você dividir as doses,
mais você vai potencializar a absorção.
Então é bem interessante.
e a cucumina, a cúrcuma, né, de modo
geral, é bom que você utilize a pimenta
preta e um óleo e uma gordura de boa
qualidade para aumentar aí a
biodisponibilidade e a absorção. Então é
uma boa coisa tomar cúrcuma junto com as
refeições,
utilizando gordura saudável como óleo de
coco e a pimenta preta.
Agora está falando de desempenho
esportivo, certo?
Então,
quanto a isso, em relação aos seus
treinos específicos
e possíveis interações com o estado de
saúde individual, é bom você ver isso de
maneira personalizada.
Então, é interessante tá vendo com
profissional da nutrição ou médico em
consulta médica para ter certeza que não
tá tendo nenhum tipo de choque entre os
suplementos.
Boa noite, doutor. Qual que é a sua
opinião sobre esses resultados? Minha
médica disse que são normais e típicos
da idade, 61 anos. Sinto cansaço,
aumento de peso, cas de cabelo. TSH de
4, ferritina de 133,
T4 livre 09.
T3 livre 3,47,
vitamina D47, B12 656, LDL 129, HDL 56,
tá tal.
Bem, o seu TSH tá no limite superior e o
T4, T3 L no limite inferior. Isso pode
ser um hipotiroismo funcional, mas tem
que ser visto em consultório, tá?
Lembrando, pessoal, que o objetivo
dessas lives não é fazer consultas
informais, tá?
A tua sintomatologia de cansaço,
gan de peso, queda de cabelo pode ser
por conta
do hipotiroidismo subclínico. Então,
talvez fosse bom você tomar uma
suplementação com os minerais,
nutrientes para maximizar a função
tiroidiana.
A gente gosta de deixar o T3 livre no
terceiro ou quarto quartice, tá?
Importante
então você marcar uma consulta e pedir
pro médico solicitar os anticorpos
antipo e antitiroglobulina para
investigar um possível haximoto.
Ultração da tireoide para ver isso
também.
Um exame completo de sangue para ver
outros marcadores, vê se você não tem
anemia, por exemplo. Avaliação de função
hepática também.
Isso tudo pode ser importante, tá?
Agora, o perfil lipídico parece tá bom.
que isso não é uma preocupação no
momento.
Apesar aí de o LDL tá acima do ideal, o
HDL colesterol em relação ao
triglicérides,
está bom, porque o triglicides está
abaixo do dobro do HDL colesterol. OK?
Então, hipótese principal hipotiroidismo
subclínico precisa marcar um agendamento
com algum médico que entenda disso.
Quais os melhores suplementos para quem
pratica corrida? Digo para ter menos
fadiga, exportar mais tempo durante a
endurance.
Então, eu pensaria em
a creatina,
né, para aumentar aí o ATP. Eu pensaria
em betalanina para aumentar os depósito
de carnosina nos músculos e ter o efeito
de tamponamento
eh do lactato que provoca a fadiga, tá?
Então, betalanina, creatina,
outra coisa, pode pensar é a citrulina
que aumenta os níveis de óxido nítrico
através do aumento da arginina. Isso
pode provocar vaso dilatação, melhora da
do desempenho no exercício.
Ah, aí tem uma parte mais polêmica,
porque tem muitos corredores que fazem
dieta cetogênica e tem melhor desempenho
sem precisar de carboidrato, tá? Mas no
mundo da corrida é muito comum se
orientar, utilizar alguns carboidratos
durante as provas como autodestrina.
Então vai de você.
Eu
sou mais fã
da cetogênica usar ácidos grassos e
copos cetôos como fonte de energia, mas
é pras ache no mundo da corrida utilizar
maltodestrina
ou waximase, né, que são carboidratos
que não vão dar pico glicêmico durante a
prova
e pode aumentar o desempenho para quem
não quer fazer cetogênica.
Além dessas aí que eu já falei, você
poderia estar pensando em vitamina D3,
K2, magnésio, os básicos, né? Ô3, um
protein de boa qualidade, um protein
isolado ou uma mistura de isolado com
hidrolizado.
Lembrando que a suplementação nunca
substitui uma alimentação adequada. Tá
bom? Boa sorte.
Meu marido tem 68 anos e a misténa deu
15.
Tem quatro pontes safena em 2004.
Acompanha com cárdio que não viu
problema nessa mostivamínico,
suplementa com B12 metilado, né? O seu
recomenda o uso de complexo B para ele é
outra recomendação?
Sim, recomendo, né? Se a mocina tá alta,
tem que dar complexo B, especialmente
B2, B6, B9, B12. Mas muitas vezes a
mocistena de 15 não baixa só com esses
quatro. Aí você tem que utilizar também
colina. creatina, ômega-3,
NAC, trimetiloglicina, tá? Depende
muito, tá? A moceína é um marcador que
ele pega uma encruzilhada metabólica,
então muita coisa pode aumentar uma
citeína. Função renal ruim pode aumentar
citeína, deficiência de vitaminas pode
aumentar inflamações em geral, alguns
cânceres,
tronombos podem aumentar, infecção pode
aumentar, tem muita coisa que pode
aumentar o citeína.
E apesar dos cardiologistas não
valorizarem, né,
existe estudos falando que aosina
elevada aumenta o risco de doença
cardiovascular, doença coronariana em
até 32%.
Tá? Então é isso que eu já comentei
aqui.
B2, B6, B9ilada,
NAC, trimetiloglicina,
colina, creatina, são todas as coisas
que baixam o cisteína e também avaliar
os níveis de vitamina D, o zinco às
vezes baixo também pode aumentar
a homocisteína, tá?
A alimentação tem que focar em evitar
excesso de meteonina, que é aminoácido,
tá?
Então, seria basicamente essa orientação
que eu tenho para te para te dar.
Ã,
eu não vi a minha primeira pergunta. Se
foi respondida, acredito que não. Não
sei do que você tá falando. Eu comecei a
responder agora as perguntas, pois na
live da semana passada teve um problema.
Assista o vídeo que tá gravado, pode ser
que eu tenha respondido, tá? Pergunto o
seguinte: "Meu filho tem 41 anos, me
parece saudável, está se queixando de
sentir muita vontade de urinar a ponto
de quase não poder segurar. No momento
está trabalhando com motorista
aplicativo, passa bastantes horas
sentado. Tem alguma sugestão, opinião?
Eu já respondi isso semana passada, tá?
Mas eu vou falar de novo para em
respeito. Mas tá lá no vídeo gravado, é
só você voltar. É porque vocês às vezes
não assistem ao vivo e vocês se esquecem
que tá tudo gravado, né? Bem, pode ser
compressão das estruturas pélvicas
porque tá sentado muitas horas do dia,
pode ser desidratação pelo ar
condicionado do carro, pode ser
constipação
intestinal que aumenta a pressão
intraabdominal, comprimindo a bexiga.
Pode causar também inflamação pélvica.
Se ele tá evitando urinar por falta de
oportunidade durante o dia, se pode
piorar a irritabilidade da bexiga,
causar a bexiga hiperativa,
o ou mesmo a síndrome da bexiga dolorosa
ou uma cistinte tercial, né? Primeiro
investigar se ele tem constipação, gases
intestinais, corrigir, se for o caso,
aumentando as fibras, né, que são os
prébióticos e às vezes usar pós-biótico
também.
Daí fazer pausas, né, da corrida do do
Uber a cada uma ou duas horas para se
mover, alongar o assoalho, fazer
exercício, alongamento, ir no banheiro
quando tiver vontade,
ã, verificar se não tá com infecção
urinária, passar em avaliação com o
urologista para ver se ele não tem
bicherativa, tá bom? Seria isso. Mas
veja lá também a resposta do vídeo da
semana passada.
Gente, evita de fazer pergunta muito
longa, tá?
se possível.
Boa noite. O senhor fez um vídeo falando
dos benefícios do LDN, me interessou
sobre uso no Alzheimer. A médica
integrativa da minha cidade não conhece
o estudo. Ah, LDN mais alfalipoico, D3 e
K2. O paciente já faz tratamento com
alto emozônio e ozônio retal. Vai
iniciar auricular. O senhor também falou
que seria uma ótima alternativa ao
protocolo somas terapias. Um vídeo fala
IDN a partir de 1,5 mg.
Alfalipôico três vezes por semana. É
isso? Ah sim. Travenoso. E oral duas
vezes ao dia nos dias que não foi
injetado. Quais as doses ideais do alfa
lipoico, do d3 e K2 em caso declíme
cognitivo recente de M1 para M2?
A médica falou em protocolo de 5 semanas
para alfa semanal,
mas no caso de aplicação das três vezes
por semana, qual é o tempo ideal?
Minha dose do alfalipoico, eu falei na
na outra na outra live, né?
Geralmente é de 200 no oral é de 200 a
300 mg duas vezes ao dia, tá?
Essa que é a dose oral.
E na aplicação endovenosa, eu não vou
ficar falando aqui porque isso aí já é
coisa para
médicos especificamente, tá? Não, não é
o objetivo daqui a gente ficar passando
também dose de coisa injetável.
Obviamente cada caso é único,
tem que considerar
que o paciente já tá fazendo o zone.
Isso é bom.
E assim, gente, tem que fazer a
individualização das doses, tá? Eu não
quero aqui ficar gravando as doses
injetáveis para depois a pessoa tomar
isso como absoluto e depois falar que
fui eu que indiquei, sendo que eu nem
atendi esse paciente.
A médica falou em protocolo de cinco
semanas para alfa semanal. Pode ser
quatro a cinco semanas, mas no caso da
aplicação das três vezes de semana, qual
o tempo ideal? Tempo ideal do quê?
Quantas semanas? Eu faria quatro a cinco
semanas primeiro, depois eu faria
avaliação, tá?
Vitamina D3 é a dose suficiente para
você ter no sangue entre 50 e 70, tá? K2
seria 100 a 200 microg por dia. Tá bom,
Dra. Alan, óleo de coco e abóbora. Quais
os benefícios se usados juntos pode
ajudar contra a calvice? Sim, o óleo de
abóbora ele tem algumas substâncias que
podem ajudar, tem efeito anti
c alfa redutase e pode ajudar na
calvice, tá?
O óleo de coco, ele tem um efeito
interessante de hidratação profunda, ele
ajuda a manter os fios também, tá?
Fortalece os fios.
E o óleo de coro também tem propriedades
antifúng e antibacterianas que podem
ajudar a equilibrar microbiota, evitar
queda.
Pode melhorar também a circulação
sanguínea dentro do couro cabeludo,
tá? Mas assim, o o óleo de semente de
abóbora,
ele não é tão específico para queda de
cabelo, tá? Ele é mais utilizado para
próstata, mas como tem o efeito cinco
alfa redutase deve ajudar nisso também.
Próximo. A estratégia de zinco,
pastilhas e vitamina C que o senhor
colocou no vídeo, serve também para essa
tal gripe K aí. Aqui em casa já
compramos própolis verde em cápsulas
também para combater essa gripe.
Sim. o zinco e a vitamina C vai
funcionar para qualquer tipo de virose,
tá?
Mas o estudo que nós comentamos era para
resfriado comum.
E essa gripe K é também conhecida como
H3N2,
é influenza, né, que é o vírus da gripe.
Então vai funcionar, vai ajudar o zinco,
vai ajudar a vitamina C, mas não espere
o mesmo resultado que por um resfriado.
Então é válido sim o própolis verde, a
vitamina C, o zinco. Só tome cuidado com
as expectativas quanto ao resultado, que
não vai ser tão forte quanto um
resfriado comum, tá?
O efeito não vai ser tão positivo, que
eu quero dizer.
Como perder gordura na barriga? Isso aí
é uma coisa que o pessoal cisma achando
que tem que fazer abdominal, que aí vai
perder mais gordura porque tá fazendo
abdominal. A pessoa vai perder gordura
no corpo inteiro se fizer uma dieta, tá?
Especialmente low carb com défic
calórico e vai perdendo a barriga, vai
perder na coxa, vai perder no tórax, vai
perder em qualquer lugar.
Essa história de perder na barriga
especificamente, não é assim que
acontece, tá? O organismo ele
ele vai escolhendo primeiro os
territórios
de gordura visceral para se livrar da
gordura, depois vai
tendo essa queima de gordura subcutânea,
tá?
Se seria uma gordura subcutânea,
depende. Tem gente que tem aquela
barriguinha e de chope, né, que a
gordura é visceral, tá? Não é gordura
subicultânea, não.
E aí não é só uma questão de calorias, é
uma questão de inflamação crônica. Aí
tem que fazer uma dieta que restrinja a
resistência insulínica, que seria uma
dieta lowcab. Aí tem que aumentar a
gordura saudável, cortar o carboidrato
especialmente refinado
e fazer atividade física e reduzir a
quantidade de calorias e fazer um jejum
intermitente também, tá? E obviamente
investigar o intestino para ver se não
tem disbiose, investigar o sono para ver
se o sono não tá ruim, que atrapalha o
emagrecimento, investigar os níveis de
estresse que cortisol desulado também
atrapalha o emagrecimento, investigar os
níveis de vitamina D3, os marcadores
inflamatórias, proteína ser reativa,
homocisteína,
fazer os exames de glicemia de jejum,
insulina de jejum,
tá? Tudo isso é importante.
Às vezes é uma questão hormonal também,
tá? Tem que ver os hormônios, os ditos
hormônios sexuais, ver como é que tá a
situação.
Como você é nutrólogo e preciso de uma
resposta exata, por favor, me ajude. Eu
uso bórax, uma colher de chá de 5 g.
para cada litro de água usando 40 ml do
preparo por dia. Eu posso tomar junto
com o três pontos de 03 letras.
Num grupo em espanhol, o líder disse que
sim, mas não confiei. Desculpe o
assunto, mas não tenho como saber,
tá? Primeira coisa, eu nunca
analisei profundamente essa questão do
borax aí, tá?
para para essas aplicações que você tá
falando aí.
Essa história do borax eu não tô
acompanhando, sinceramente. Terei que
estudar, tá? Não tenho como responder
sobre isso.
O CDS eu já usei no passado, parei de
utilizar porque as poucas fácas que
faziam pararam de fazer por medo das
repercussões lá de uma reportagem que
saiu no Fantástico. Então hoje em dia eu
não me pronuncio mais sobre o CDS, tá?
Então eu oriento as pessoas a buscar
informações no site do Andreas Calker,
OK? Comprar últimos livros que ele
lançou. Isso é por sua própria conta,
tá? Não, não é uma coisa que eu possa me
manifestar a respeito.
Estude, leia e tome suas próprias
conclusões sobre o uso do CDS e do MMS,
tá? O bórax, eu não posso falar a
respeito porque eu não estudei esse
assunto.
Já usei no passado CDS, mas hoje em dia
não consigo mais usar, então prefiro me
omitir a respeito e pedir para as
pessoas estudarem o assunto no site do
Andreas Calker ou comprando o livro
dele.
Estava querendo informações sobre o uso
de água com hidrogênio molecular. Qual a
marca da garrafa mais recomendável? A
quantidade diária de gestão?
Boa pergunta. Eu tava recomendando até
pouco tempo atrás o HRO Max, tá? Que eu
tenho uma garrafinha deles aqui.
Eh,
entende que houve um problema e os
sócios brigaram, tá? Então eu tô um
pouco inseguro agora
sobre como é que ficou a situação da
Hidron Gmax.
Tem uma marca aí que eu vi falar, mas eu
não testei ainda. É uma tal de Blue Vida
HW Max, tá?
Ela tem uma tecnologia mais avançada com
membrana.
E então você poderia estar
experimentando essa
em relação ao consumo, água hidrogenada
seria seguro para consumo diário. OK. É
bem seguro.
Eu mesmo tomo.
Não tem assim uma um volume exato de de
quanto tomar, mas eu eu tomaria entre
500 ml e 1 L por dia, tá?
Da hidrogenada, né? E complementando com
água normal para dar de um de 1,5 a 2,5
por dia, dependendo do tamanho da pessoa
e da nível de atividade física, tá?
É, até acho que difícil você tomar 2 L
de água hidrogenada por dia, porque você
não vai lembrar de ficar toda hora
hidrogenando a água. Então eu tomaria
entre 500 ml e 1 L por dia. Bom,
o que fazer no carro de avançado? Algo
que amenize o sofrimento? Boa pergunta.
Bem, eh, vê se responde a dona Epesila,
se responde a memantina,
usar extrato de cannabis para reduzir aí
o distúrbio de sono e também a agitação,
que é muito comum nesses pacientes,
seriam já boas medidas aí para minimizar
o sofrimento.
Eu nem propor, nesse caso, o protocolo
recode, porque para um paciente que já
tá com quadro avançado é muito difícil
mudar os hábitos, né? já vai ser muito
difícil mudar alimentação, não vai fazer
atividade física, não vai fazer
treinamento cerebral, não vai conseguir
fazer o protocolo direito. Então não
recomendo o recode para um caso já está
com diagnóstico de avançado. Então é
minimizar o sofrimento do paciente da
família, né, utilizando
strato de cannabis, se responder bem a
memantina, dá, se responder bem a
donepesila dá.
Pode usar uma estimulação
biofotomodulação, né? Aquele capacete de
luz pode ajudar. Pode usar também
eletroestimulação
cerebral, o magnetismo cerebral, tá?
Esses três aí são terapias de suporte
que já tem bastante benefício.
Se a agitação não melhorar com canabis,
pode pensar em tomar doses baixas de
ketiapina para dormir melhor, tá? Pode
também entrar com musicoterapia, pode
ajudar.
E principalmente quem cuida do cuidador,
né? As pessoas que cuidam desses idosos
ficam muito estressadas e adoecem
também. Então é muito importante que se
dê suporte ao cuidador.
Então a dica principal seria extrato de
cannabis, tá? Especialmente esses
extratos que têm meio a meio com THC,
isso podem ajudar bastante.
Doutor, qual que é a melhor marca e
dosagem de LDN para quem tem doença
autoimune? Geralmente a gente começa com
1,5 mg e vai subindo até 4,5, tá? Se for
rashimoto, a prática é manter em um
e-mail. Geralmente a gente não sobe mais
que um e-mail, tá?
E não é uma questão de marca, você vai
fazer isso na manipulação, né? Então não
tem marca, é só garantir que você tá
utilizando uma manipulação de qualidade
idônea, né? Eu recomendo a integritar
para os membros da comunidade nossa.
Aqui
tem gente que é muito sensível LDN, pode
ser que tome dose até abaixo de 1,5 mg,
mas aí se não for Rashimoto pode ir
subindo de 1,5 para 3 e de 3 para 4,5.
Agora, se você mora fora do Brasil, não
sei onde que você mora, Elizabeth, tem
alguns sites internacionais que vendem,
tem o site do ldnresearch.org,
que tem as fontes internacionais de
compra lá.
Grávidas ou pessoas que querem
engravidar, quais os melhores
suplementos para a gestação e a
quantidade de refeições por dia? Sei que
tem muito diabetes gestacional
e quero evitar comer várias vezes para
não ter isso.
Bem, principal suplemento para gestação
é metfolato,
que é a forma ativa do ácido fólico.
O segundo é o ferro, porque é bem comum
mulher grávida ficar com anemia. O
terceiro seria a vitamina D3, muito
muito importante.
O quarto seria ômega-3, fundamental pro
desenvolvimento sério do bebê.
O quinto seria vitamina B12.
O sexto seria magnésio e o sétimo seria
iodo, tá? Seria esses os principais.
e obviamente fazer os exames durante a o
acompanhamento pré-natal para ver se não
vai precisar corrigir alguma alteração
de exame, tá?
E o mais importante é a qualidade da
alimentação e não a quantidade de vezes
você vai comer pro dia.
É importante ter gordura boa, é
importante ter proteína, é importante
ter vegetais coloridos, cortar os
processados, industrializados. É a mesma
história que eu falo sempre.
Quando a mulher come demais carboidrato
na gravidez, vai parar insulina e ela
pode ter diabetes gestacional, que é
péssimo pro bebê, tá? Então, corra dos
carboidratos simples, dos açúcares e dos
doces, tá certo? Pode comer três
refeições principais bem estruturadas,
né? E evitar esses lanches porcaria aí
que pessoal gosta de comer bolacha,
biscoito, bolo, pão, essas coisas.
Doutor, duas refeições por dia, tem
algum problema, moça e janta? Nenhum,
tá? Não, nenhum. Pelo contrário, tem
muita gente se beneficia cortando uma
das refeições, tá?
O que existe alguma polêmica se vale a
pena não pular o café da manhã? Então,
tem estudos que falam que não é bom
pular o café da manhã
por conta aí de uma questão do fenômeno
do avorecer, que a glicose de manhã
cedo, ela tende a dar picos em algumas
pessoas e quando você toma café da
manhã, você consegue controlar esse pico
de glicose, por incrível que pareça.
tem um estudo com diabéticos tipo dois
que mostrou uma perda maior eh de de
peso e controle do diabetes com duas
refeições grandes comparado à seis
pequenas.
Teve também um melhor controle da
gordura do fígado e da sensibilidade da
insulina.
O espaçamento maior entre aseções em
algumas pessoas mantém insulina em
níveis mais baixos durante o dia. Isso
pode controlar melhor a fome e ajudar na
oxidação da gordura corporal.
Então, existe essa polêmica, tá? Eh, eh,
talvez seja melhor você tomar o café da
manhã e fazer um almoço bem mais tarde,
eh, que seria o almoço barra janta, tá?
É o mais saudável do que pular o café da
manhã, segundo os estudos. Então, você
poderia, por exemplo, tomar um café da
manhã às 8 da manhã e comer depois às 15
ou 16 horas, como se fosse almoço,
almoço barra janta, tá?
Essa é uma estratégia também que você
pode experimentar.
Doutor Alan, qual a diferença entre
hidrocortisona e hidrocortisona base?
Depende. Na fumaça de manipulação,
pelo menos uma fumaça de manipulação de
boa qualidade, eh, não vai ter
diferença, tá? O que acontece é, se você
for numa farmácia muito barateira, eles
vão trocar hidrocortisona
por uma um cortisol lá vagabundo, se
você não especificar que é hidrocortisol
na base. Se eu colocar só cortisol, por
exemplo, eles vão colocar uma um acetato
de cortisol, que é uma porcaria.
Tem uma amiga de 80 anos que toma
hidrocortisona por anos,
por uma médica que disse para ela que
não tinha ideia de que como ela poderia
interromper o uso desse medicamento.
Não, na verdade tem que desmamar sim.
Isso não é para tomar pro resto da vida,
não, tá?
Só se ela tiver,
digamos assim,
confirmado doença de Adson,
aí ela poderia, deveria tomar o resto da
vida, mas se não tiver Adson, isso aí
deveria ser desmamado, sim. Tá?
Então é bom colocar hidrocortis na base
porque algumas farmácias piores aí de
qualidade podem trocar pelo acetato, né,
que é uma porcaria, tá?
Se ela tá tomando já hidrocorzona há
muitos anos, provavelmente as glândulas
adenais dela estão atróficas e vai ser
mais difícil de tirar.
Então tem que fazer um desmame muito
cuidadoso
e dá suporte adrenal com vitamina C,
pantotenado de cálcio, que é a vitamina
B5,
com complexo B adaptógenos, o DEA, né?
Ah, quando tiver disponível a
pregnenulona,
tá bom?
Então possível é difícil que se torna
porque tem anos que ela já toma, né?
Deixa eu ligar o de novo aqui que
começou a ficar quente aqui de novo.
É necessário receita médica para comprar
lítio orotato? Não, porque atualmente
você só compra em sites internacionais
na internet, então não precisa
manipulação. Você não vai achar orotato
de lítio,
tá? Não adianta nem indicar porque não
tem na formagem de manipulação. Tem que
comprar no site. Eu tava indicando o
IERB, mas o IERB eu tenho checado lá.
Eles não estão tendo mais ot de lítio,
eles estão tendo outra forma de lítio
lá.
Então eu comprarei no site do Life
Extension que tá vendendo o rotado de
lítio da CAL, tá?
Agora, se você achar em Mercado Livre,
na Amazon, que são marketplaces, né,
pode comprar se for de marca confiável.
A marca K L é uma das marcas melhor.
Então, o hordar de lítio, ele é mais
para estabilizar o humor e prevenir
doenças neurológicas, tá? Ele dá um
suporte ao humor e bem-estar, mas ele
não tem um efeito direto sobre o sono,
tá?
Ele vai estudar suporte, é um bom sono,
mas não vai ser um medicamento principal
para isso.
Certo,
Dr. Alão, magnésio, ô3, a creatina pode
tomar sem pausas? Sim, pode, sem
problema nenhum, tá?
Lógico, existe o risco teórico de você
tomar excesso de magnésio, tá? Então,
tome cuidado, não faça isso sem
acompanhamento médico. Creatina pode
aumentar os marcadores
uré e creatinina. Então, tomar cuidado
com isso, porque isso não quer dizer que
tá ferrando o rim, mas pode gerar
confusões a na análise de exames.
Então, se você não tiver fazendo
acompanhamento com o médico, não tiver
fazendo exame, é melhor fazer eh ciclos,
né? Tome três meses, pare um mês, ou
tome 3 meses, parees, tá?
Então, tome cuidado só com isso.
Qual o nome daquele aparelho cetose que
a nutricionista Andrea Torres lhe deu de
presente para que eu verifique aqui no
Mercado Livre? Você não vai achar não.
Não tem no Brasil. Um parente meu dos
Estados Unidos virá o Brasil. Esse
aparelho é chinês e o representante dele
é da Itália. Tá, a gente tá vendo uma
maneira de trazer ele pro Brasil, mas
também negociação ainda,
tá? Mas o nome, caso você queira saber,
deixa eu ver aqui, porque eu mesmo é CBI
CM. Vou mostrar aqui para vocês, ó. Tá
dando para ver aí?
CBIO CM, tá? É o nome do
S I B I O CM.
No YouTube você recomendou para micose
na unha pegar três gotas de óleo de
orégano mais duas gotas de óleo
melaleuca.
Quatro vezes por dia. O espaçamento
entre esses quatro vezes pode ser de 2
horas ou tem que ser mais?
Após pingar tem algum problema se
colocar meio e sapato?
Bem, 2 horas é um tempo muito curto, tá?
Você pode tá
colocando quatro vezes ao dia, tá?
Então, a cada 5 ou 6 horas
para deixar o óleo agir bastante.
Seria bom deixar um tempo pro dedo sem
unha, tá? Desculpa, sem meia, tá?
Porque se você cobre logo em seguida,
você pode est causando umidade e pode tá
atrapalhando a ação do óleo essencial
pela umidade e ela favorece o
crescimento da micose.
Então é bom secar bem a região e deixar
agir pelo menos 30 minutos antes de
colocar meia, tá?
Se a pessoa comer muita quantidade de
costela suína todos os dias, ela vai
engordar por causa do excesso de
proteína ou por causa da gordura?
Depende da quantidade, né, Eliseu? Óbvio
que se você passar de um certo ponto é
caloria. Por mais que a gente recomenda
aqui dieta lowcarb,
se você se entupir de proteína ou de
gordura, você vai engordar. É muito
difícil alguém se entupir muito de
gordura, porque a gordura é muito
saciante e depois de um certo ponto ele
até da náusea, então é difícil. Mas
proteína pelo pelo outro lado,
proteína é fácil de você passar do ponto
você gosta de comer muita carne.
Não, eh, pelo que eu saibo, a gordura
boa não engorda, mesmo consumido em
grande quantidade. Não é verdade isso,
tá? Existe duas coisas que você tem que
levar em consideração. Primeiro, o
efeito metabólico da comida, que a gente
fala muito aqui, que tem que cortar
carboidrato por causa da questão da
resistência insulínica. Mas lembrando
que vários aminoácidos que tem nos
alimentos com proteína tem efeito
glicogênico, tem a neoglicênese, que é a
formação de glicose a partir de
aminoácido.
Então, se você comer proteína demais,
vai engordar sim, vai ter até
resistência insulínica se comer proteína
demais.
Lembrando que essa costela suína tem que
ser feita sem aquele molho açucarado que
é tão comum, né? Um molho barbecue, né?
Isso daí é uma é um grande,
né, armadilha, uma grande armadilha que
tem nesses tipos de comida, né? Muita
gente come com esse molho aí, aí lasca,
né?
Mas se você comer essa costela suína sem
esses molhos aí que estragam, né, vai
ter que comer uma quantidade maior para
realmente ter esse excesso aí de caloria
e pode engordar, mas pode engordar sim,
tá? Não tem essa história que pode comer
tanto que quer não.
Na live passada você disse a respeito da
dieta carnívora. Se a pessoa bebe água
suficiente, come víceras, come músculos,
não é todo mundo que fica constipado,
não. Existe uma compensação do
intestino. Me explica como é que é essa
compensação.
Então, vamos lá.
Quando você bebe água o suficiente, você
mantém a umidade do polo fecal, esfça
litrânsito,
mesmo sem o volume adicional que as
fibras forneceriam, tá? E as víceras,
elas são ricas em colágeno, elastina,
vários sais minerais, gorduras
específicas que podem nutrir diretamente
a mucosa do intestino epitélio. Isso vai
ajudar a manter a integridade da
barreira intestinal. E além disso, para
algumas pessoas que têm disbiose ou
inflamação intestinal crônica, essa
redução de carboidratos fermentáveis é
benéfica. Ela vai diminuir a fermentação
bacteriana e vai reduzir desconforto
ligado aos gases,
ok?
E também existe uma reorganização da
microbiota,
né, em relação a à proteína que você tá
ingerindo. Então é possível que a
proteína da dieta sozinha já segure a
questão da flora intestinal e não
precise tanta fibra vegetal assim, tá?
Lógico que essa adaptação é individual e
é muito variável de pessoa para pessoa.
Tem gente que vai constipar muito
comendo só vícera e carne e vai ter
pessoa que vai ter um ritmo intestinal
normal, tá? Então isso é variável. Aí eu
recomendo a pessoa que tá fazendo uma
uma dieta carnívora estrita, que eu acho
que é quase ninguém, porque o pessoal
fala que tá fazendo carnívora, mas na no
fundo tá comendo vegetal, mas vamos
falar que esteja fazendo a estrita, que
é quase ninguém. Aí você simplesmente
introduz nas folhas, né? Introduz alguns
legumes que você sabe que você não tem
tolerância, tá?
Então, o problema é que a gente tem
poucos estudos ainda com a dieta
carnívora, né? É uma dieta que,
infelizmente, não
atsou muito interesse dos institutos de
pesquisa, das faculdades. Então, tem
pouco estudo, tem que ter mais estudos
com mais gente pra gente chegar a
conclusões mais definitivas, né?
Mas pode funcionar muito bem para
algumas pessoas.
Olá, Dra. Alã, qual o melhor horário
para tomar fosfatilio colina 420 mg duas
vezes ao dia? Preferencialmente com as
refeições, tá? Então você faz isso com
as duas principais refeições do dia,
porque é um ativo
liposolúvel, tá? Ele é um fóspolipídio,
então ele vai ser beneficiado o consumo
junto com alimentos com gordura.
É bom evitar tomar em jejum que pode dar
desconforto gastrointestinal, tá?
Qual o melhor laboratório pro maleato de
nalapril?
Bem, eu não vou saber responder essa
pergunta da melhor forma porque eu não é
um assunto que me interessa muito
estudar.
Eh, eu vou dar uma resposta mais
genérica, mais especial, mas realmente
eu não nunca me interessei em aprofundar
nas diferenças entre os genéricos que
são aprovados pela Anvisa, teoricamente
seriam iguais, tá? Eh, teoricamente a
Anvisa fez estudos de biodisponibilidade
e todos os genéricos que estão aí no
mercado seriam a mesma coisa, teria
bioequivalência.
Agora, marcas aí que são consolidadas de
genérico, é o MS, é o Simed, é o Medley,
a neoquímica, Teutto, Sand, até onde se
essas marcas são confiáveis, tá?
Então, na prática,
eu não diria que me parece que tem
diferença significativa entre esses
produtos dessas marcas que eu comentei,
tá?
Às vezes você tem alguma reação com
alguma marca de genérico, se você troca
pode não ter reação por conta dos
excipientes, né, que são os enchimentos
das cápsulas. Então você pode
experimentar, por exemplo, da MS, se
você não se deu bem, tentar da Sandou
tentar eh de outra empresa como a
Simédia, a Medley, tá? Então, eh, vale a
pena caso você sinta alguma piora no
caso.
Preciso de uma resposta exata, por
favor, me ajude. Não, essa eu já
respondi, já respondi, tá repetida.
Boa noite. É normal suplementação
diária de 20 mg de zinquelado, mesmo não
estando de estômago vazio, a pessoa cite
mal vez ou outra a ponto de vomitar ou
seria alguma disfunção do organismo.
Não. O zinco ele pode atacar o estômago,
sim. Essa dose não é muito alta, mas
você pode ser sensível ao zinco,
mas geralmente não é comum, porque essa
dose aí não é uma dose alta não.
E a ideia de quelar o zinco, que é
juntar o zinco com aminoáculo foi
principalmente pensado para aumentar
absorção e também reduzir irritação
gástrica.
Bem, aí vale a pena fazer o quê? reduzir
a dose individual, né? Tom uma dose
menor
ou aí até recomendo investigar se não
tem um problema aí de permeabilidade
intestinal
aumentada, um liquigante, uma disbiose,
né, que possa estar contribuindo para
essa intolerância.
Pode experimentar tomar o zinco junto
com alimento, especialmente uma gordura
saudável, que vai diminuir a absorção e
vai diminuir o desconforto, diminuir a a
velocidade da absorção, não diminuir a
quantidade da absorção, tá?
Se mesmo tomando com alimento persistir
o desconforto, para de tomar,
tá certo?
e reduza ou reduza a dose da de cada
cápsula para tentar ver a tolerância.
Tá vendo, gente? Tem muita pergunta
hoje, eu não vou conseguir responder ao
vivo, tá? Amocina abaixo de sete é
motivo para preocupação?
Não. Eh, entre seis e sete, tá OK? Tá. O
que eu ficaria preocupado seria umaina
de cinco para baixo, porque aí pode ter
sim, é raro ver isso na clínica, mas
existe, né? Pode ter aí uma redução de
produção de antioxidantes e acúmulo de
algumas substâncias tóxicas, tá? Então
se tiver abaixo de cinco ou cinco, tem
que ficar de olho nisso daí.
Mas o que eu vejo com muito mais
frequência é aumento da mussteína.
Tem casos aí, por exemplo, de
homocisteina baixa que a gente pode
suplementar com meteonina, tá? Meteonina
para aumentar a homocisteína se tiver
muito baixa ou verificar qual é a causa
dessa redução da da homosten.
Olá, Dr. Alan. alguns protocolos, como
no, por exemplo, o método Win Hof, onde
uma das técnicas é o banho de gelo, é
orientado para quem tiver dificuldade
iniciar com banho frio após tomar um
banho quente de costume.
Sim, é verdade.
Isso poderia causar um choque térmico ou
algum prejuízo paraa saúde? Não. O
choque térmico é justamente o que você
quer, né? Eh, na verdade, o que se
falava muito antigamente, que você não
pode tomar friagem, não pode tomar
choque têmico, isso é parcialmente
verdade. Isso aí acontece quando a
pessoa tá com sistema imune mais fraco.
O choque térmico pode facilitar que a
pessoa pegue uma virose. Mas é
exatamente isso. Dentro do protocolo de
pensando em estender a vida, né, de
maneira saudável, é você quer estimular
as chamadas chaperonas, que são as
proteínas que são ativadas quando você
faz o choque térmico.
Eh, hitsock protein ou chaperona são o
nome dessas proteínas que são ativadas
com choque térmico.
E quando você não tá acostumado
fazer essa transição gradual do banho
quente pro frio, é o protocolo de
segurança para você ir ir pegando o
jeito da coisa e aumentar a tolerância,
né?
Você começa com 15 a 30 segundos de água
fria. 15 a 30 segundos de água fria.
Após o banho quente, vai aumentando esse
tempo progressivamente ao longo de
algumas semanas para aumentar a
tolerância.
Agora, pessoas que não podem fazer isso,
pessoas que têm doença cardíaca
descontrolada, pressão alta também não
controlada, epilepsia, pessoas que têm
reações de oticária ao frio, pessoas que
têm símbolo de Renault, insufência
renal, isso aí não pode fazer, tá?
Dor de cabeça pode estar associado ao
excesso de alumínio. Sim, é um dos
sintomas de excesso de alumínio, mas tem
que checar porque tem centenas de outras
causas para dor de cabeça, né?
O alumínio quando tá acumulando no
organismo, ele pode causar alterações
neurológicas que dá sintoma de dor de
cabeça, enxaqueca, tontura e vertigem,
tá? De novo, sintoma de alumínio, dor de
cabeça, enxaqueca, tontura e vertigem.
O alumínio ele acumula no cérebro e vai
interferindo nos processos bioquímicos
nos neurônios. Vai comprometer a
absorção de nutrientes essenciais, cria
um ambiente propício para esses sintomas
e o alumínio pode se acumular no
estômago e causar desconfortos que se
irradiam como enxaqueca.
Lembrando que a principal fonte de
alumínio é desodorante,
panelas,
alimentos processados, né? Tem aquelas
embalagens de alumínio.
Antiasso também é uma fonte comum de
alumínio.
Então, vale a pena ver os níveis de
alumínio no sangue e na urina,
porque é uma coisa bem comum.
intoxicação por alumínio.
O uso contínuo de P5P, que é o
períodoxal 5 fosfato, que é a vitamina
B6 ativa, né, na dose de 30 mg diária,
pode ser nociva ao organismo? Se sim,
qual seria a dose segura? Não, é bem
seguro essa dose aí, tá? É bem tolerado.
Não, nunca vi problema com essa dose,
não.
Na verdade, para dar problema tem que
ser dose muito mais elevada.
seria 10 vezes essa dose aí pelo menos.
Aí seria neuropatia periférica,
dormência,
dificuldade de marcha
e geralmente aparece com doses acima de
500 mg por dia.
Então 30 mg é super seguro, tá?
Só se você tivesse usando dose muito
alta mesmo, tipo mais de 200 mg por dia
pro período longos. Então fique
tranquilo.
D Alan, lactoferrina bovina isolada pode
ajudar a queelar o ferro do marcador do
índice de saturação transferrina acima
de 80%.
Considerando ferro sérico fer normais
até 200.
Sim, é possível. A lactoferina bovina
pode sequestrar ferro.
A eficácia pode ser limitada nesse
cenário que você tá me falando aí. A
lactoferrina bovina
tem uma saturação de ferro entre 15 a
20%.
A humana entre 5 e 8%.
Então, a capacidade quilante bovina
é menor porque ele já tem essa saturação
de de origem, né?
Mas eu geralmente não uso lactoferina
para fazer queelação de ferro, tá?
Lactofina é mais utilizada para melhorar
sistema imuno entérico
e para até melhorar absorção de ferro em
pessoas que têm anemia, tá?
Seria importante investigar mais
profundamente a causa dessa
saturação de transferina acima de 80%,
pode ser hemocromatose,
né, e outras tras de sangue, por
exemplo.
E aí eu poderia pensar em fazer uso de
desferoxamina.
Desferoxamina,
que são os protocolos oficiais para
quear ferro, tá?
Então, de novo, a lactoferina é mais
indicada para complemento para sistema
imune e modulação de microbiota e não
como terapia quilante ferro.
Vixe Maria, tá um perguntão aqui.
Boa noite. Eu havia perguntado se
excesso de de novo essa história, gente.
Eu já falei isso na live já, gente. Teve
a live lá do
no nível dois que eu falei disso.
Eu havia perguntado se o S7 telas e o
uso constante pornografia e masturbação
compulsível podem simular sintomas do
autismo.
Em nenhum momento eu disse que isso
causa autismo. Minha pergunta é se pode
simular sintomas.
Se a pessoa tiver, eu já falei disso,
gente, se a pessoa tiver muito grudada
no no nas redes sociais, nas telas e
tudo, ela pode ficar com isolamento
social e isso pode ser uma coisa que eh
superficialmente lembra o autismo, tá?
Ela pode ter déficção, né? Ela pode ter
problema de fala porque não tá mais
falando com ninguém, não tá se
comunicando,
entendeu? Dificuldade de socialização.
Falei em tudo disso. Já
considerando que até os 10 ou 12 anos a
criança não apresentava esse seu
comportamento, é possível que esse uso
simule esses e outros sintomas?
Respondi que sim. Eu não sei porque tá
respondendo, tá perguntando de novo,
né?
Então existe um fenômeno chamado
dessensibilização do topaminégica que
acontece nessa situação de excesso de
telas ou ou de estímulos sexuais aí por
tela. E isso pode imitar um pouco
autismo. Pronto, já falei isso na outra
live também.
Que que acontece então com a masturbação
compulsível? Tem uma cascata de
problemas neurológicos. Primeiro tem uma
liberação excessiva de dopamina seguida
de uma dessensibilização,
redução de receptores e confunção do
sistema dopaminégico.
Aí vai dar aquela dificuldade de
atenção, apatia, falta de comunicação
social e pode dar disfunção sexual,
ansiedade, irritabilidade, entendeu?
problema de sono e alguns dos sintomas
lembram o autismo. É simples assim, tá?
Mas não fica se agarrando nisso porque
às vezes a pessoa tem autismo mesmo e a
pessoa fica se agarrando nisso com a
esperança que a pessoa não tem autismo,
entendeu?
Se antes dos 10 ou 12 anos não tinha
sintoma nenhum e apareceu depois do
excesso de tela e excesso de estimulação
sexual pelas telas,
então parece que claro que pode ser um
uma condição adquirida que tá imitando
um pouco o autismo, tá? Geralmente
autismo não aparece com 10, 12 anos,
aparece com antes de 2 anos de de idade,
tá bom?
E se já falei também disso, se você
cessa o estímulo, geralmente os sintomas
são reversíveis, tá?
Doutor, uma parente minha comentou que
presenciou no hospital a transferência
de um bebê que havia sofrido um AVC.
Ah, tá.
Ah, mas essa parente sua mora em
Portugal? É porque eu fiquei sabendo um
caso que repercutiu na mídia portuguesa
alguns meses atrás, que foi um
recém-nascido que sofreu hemorragia
cerebral
com gênita em Portimão, no hospital lá
que na região lá de Malgave e foi
transferido para Lisboa.
Não sei se esse caso tá falando aí.
Então, essa criança chegou muito mal lá
no no Hospital de Lisboa porque teve que
fazer todo o trajeto rodoviário, 270 km.
Não sei se você tá inferindo aí que
possa ter sido proteí spike, né? Eu não
fiquei sabendo de mais detalhes desse
caso, não.
Como você não fez uma pergunta
específica, eu acho,
não sei se você queria saber um detalhe
desse caso, mas eu só fiquei sabendo por
alto.
Dr. Se uma pessoa estiver correndo o
risco de infarto ou AVC e por acaso
beber dois copos de água sem saber, isso
pode evitar o evento? Não. Esse efeito é
apenas momentâneo. Po, vai ajudar, mas
não vai evitar se tiver com todas as
condições para um infarto, tá? A pessoa
percebe que é infartar e ter AVC?
Depende. Tem pessoas que percebem que
tem os pródromos, né, do AVC e tem gente
que não percebe. Beber água apenas
ameniza os efeitos. Sim, só vai amenizar
os efeitos. O que que ela deve fazer
para evitar que o perigo retorne?
Tá lembrando que a hidratação adequada é
para prevenção a a princípio, tá? não é
eficaz como intervenção para um evento
agudo.
Tem estudo de Rav falando redução de 53%
no risco de AVC para quem está
prevenindo, tomando água
consistentemente ao longo de vários
meses, não é para tomar na hora do
infarto ou desculpa do do AVC. OK.
Obviamente que a hidratação vai diminuir
a viscosidade do sangue, vai ajudar um
pouco, mas é só um efeito marginal, tá?
H, deixa eu ver se tem mais perguntas
aqui. Dr. Alan, os exames de sangue
solicitados permitem identificar
deficiências nutricionais que possam
indicar risco ou associação com
transtorno mental. Que exame de sangue
você tá falando? Os que eu peço no me
consultório. Tá bem vago, né? Tá, vou
vou responder como se fosse eu os exames
que eu peço, tá? Vamos lá. permitem
identificar deficiências nutricionais
que possam indicar risco. Depende. Eh,
não são todos exames de sangue
habituais que os planos autorizam que
vão ver as deficiências nutricionais.
Algumas deficiências nutricionais só vai
ser visto com áos orgânicos urinários,
exames de metabolômica,
tá? Então vai depender, grosseiramente
falando, paraa maioria dos casos, esses
exames de sangue vão ser suficientes,
mas vai ter alguns casos que vai ser
necessário fazer exames mais
sofisticados de metabolômica,
especialmente os ácidos orgânicos
urinários,
OK?
E tem exames hoje neurotransmissores
também, que não deixa de ser um exame de
metabolômica.
H, as super lives e as lives recentes da
comunidade não possuem tópicos.
Como não tem tópico,
não tô entendendo essa sua solicitação.
Num documento do resumo não tem tópico.
Pera aí, vou abrir lá para ver isso daí
se tá falando.
Pera aí.
Deixa eu ver se tá. Eu não lembro que
qual conta do Google que eu coloquei
isso. Tem que achar aqui agora.
Aqui resumo das lives nível um. Deve ser
falando aqui,
tá? tem tá organizado
em perguntas e respostas e tem um
resumo. Agora, o que você tá chamando de
tópico tá lá no na timeline do vídeo,
gente.
Lá na timeline do vídeo
tem lá o
onde começa cada assunto. É isso? tá
chamando de tópico
porque tem um documento e tem dentro dos
das lives, dentro dos vídeos, tem lá o a
marcação de tempo.
Melhor do que isso, eu não sei como tá.
Você tá olhando os vídeos lá, Renato.
Bem, gente, ó, já tem mais de uma hora
de live aqui.
Eu não vou responder as perguntas ao
vivo, tá, Eliseu?
Ah,
estranho. Estou ouvindo uma gravação
junto com a live. Como assim? É só a
Vilma que tá ouvindo isso ou tem mais
alguém?
Ah, gente, não coloquem comentários
soltos que eu não vou entender o
contexto.
A live passada, por exemplo, a anterior,
por exemplo, o quê?
Não entendi não.
Um abraço para você, irma.
Seja muito bem-vindo, viu, Gui? a nossa
comunidade.
Alguém mais tá escutando uma gravação aí
junto com a live ou é só a
Irma aí que tá escutando?
Aliás, Vilma, a Vilma que tá escutando.
Dra. Ana Paula tá dizendo nenhum ruído a
mais.
Alguém mais tá escutando alguma outra
coisa?
Apenas a minha voz. Obrigado pelo
comentário.
Só no início.
Bem, Vilma, eu acho que é uma coisa do
seu sistema aí, porque ninguém mais
falou que escutou isso, não, tá? Depois
eu vou ver a gravação. Pessoal, muito
obrigado pela participação de vocês. Foi
um grande prazer tê-los aqui. Eu queria
desejar a todos um excelente Natal, ano
novo. Pera aí que eu sumi aqui.
Pera aí. né? Tá cobrindo um pouco, mas
vou deixar assim mesmo. Então eu desejo
a vocês feliz Natal, excelentes festas
aí de final de ano.
Eu vou fazer lives normais de
terça-feira na semana que vem, né? A
terça-feira que vem vai cair no dia
30. Então vai ter live normal dia 30 e
nesse domingo que é o dia
28 nós vamos ter a live do nível dois,
tá? a super live, como vocês estão
chamando aí, tá joia?
Obrigado, Cristina, por dar o feedback.
Obrigado, Cleidan, também
bom descanso também. Feliz Natal a todos
vocês. Que muita saúde na família de
vocês, muitas alegrias, muitas
satisfações
e que o espírito natalino
preencha aí a vida de vocês, que vocês
tenham amor no coração, que vocês possam
ter momentos de qualidade com a família
e com os entes queridos, tá bom? Até
domingo para quem é do nível dois e até
semana que vem pro resto. Abraço a
vocês.